today we're going to be making gears
that are stochastically printed to have
this nice open pore structure the tools
you're going to need are a 3d printer
and the deep fryer and the ingredients
are half a cup of corn dough and a
little bit more than three quarters a
cup of water and mix it in the bowl
push it together we should have a nice
consistency where we'll stick to itself
just a little but only to itself then
we'll take a canister just kind of press
it into the back making sure to leave
the tip open to the air can escape
you just put it right on the mission
so let's make us some nice deep fried
masa so we'll make it in the shape of a
gear so just type it in try giving to
play small scale it up to size it should
work
then we click go
right now it's doing the process we call
stochastic training where it exploits a
material property no notice this gets
the right instability if you drizzle
it'll buckle and we've underneath the
spot where your trizol so here we use
that to make spiral patterns to build up
more porks 3d printable structures and
when you make a porous food structure
out of say something like corn dough
which isn't actually porous you now can
deep fry the entire thing all the way
through or if you use another material
you can imagine making a filter out of
this for even just changing the
mechanical properties of this bulk
material by introducing this
unstructured pattern to it
so now I'm going to take it and deep-fry
it so it can get nice and crispy you
could also bake it or just let it dry
out so it would firm up with it
it's done popping pull it out
it's completely at home doable anyone
can build it this one we like to call
ikea plus level skill it's a little bit
more than putting together ikea
furniture but when we release model 3 we
hope it to be around ikea level you know
just screw it together and you're good
to go
you